what up guys this video is brought to
you by Squarespace whether you need a
website online store or domain you can
make it with Squarespace Squarespace
templates make it easy to get it started
with all your online projects this year
they got a bunch of brand new templates
so you are sure to find something that's
gonna fit your specific needs
Squarespace even has award-winning
customer service and all-in-one platform
and you never have to install patch or
upgrade ever do you hear me ever and you
know what's super awesome instead of
working with multiple vendors you could
transfer all your third-party services
all to Squarespace go to Squarespace
calm for a free trial that when you're
ready to launch go to Squarespace calm /
just kidding news for 10% off of your
first domain or your first website see
you guys next time
adios two plus two is four quick mass
buy in revenge brownie news I love
brownies that will get me Oh revenge
brownie though put poison in that
brownie I'm eating it okay okay
submitted by little David so oh you
must've it so bad people always like
every month send me photos of kids that
look like you I know and it's just
always some random ugly fat aging care
nursing take a look like you did when
you was a newborn people look like me at
all it looks like Gio 100% Patel is
nothing like what to you he doesn't look
Asian at all not anymore like when he
first was born I thought I always looked
like 100% yes with all the presenting he
doesn't look Asian he looks Mexican a
hundred percent no
yeah definitely yeah look more Mexican
than Gio yeah and I made glad he looks
more like her than me that is HUGE the
rest of the world a woman was fired for
bringing laxatives filled brownies to
work did she get down perfect for
herself or was it for that size you just
can't trust people's baked goods anymore
I know I'm trying to eat everything if
you hate your coworkers that's like a
non-violent way to you know like meet
and greets and stuff do you like fans
bring you like cupcakes and [ __ ] hell
yeah all that [ __ ] you eat it I [ __ ]
ate it dude I'll go [ __ ] you know what I
do though I open it up and I haven't eat
it with me mmm what if they choose to
unpause and wine huh no there's nothing
at all no because they're not gonna
think about that I'm like eight now they
are you just gonna it's all for us I
take the one cupcake and I cut it in
half you know what I do is kind of
[ __ ] up as soon as they leave it throw
the trash can well sorry guys but I'm
scared of getting poisoned so they're
gonna poison David now they're gonna
poison half a cupcake yeah - the girl
you know cat sweets 800 she catered the
goop thing right yeah he said a lot you
know is amazing cuz all that shit's sure
she does [ __ ] bomb is [ __ ] bomb and
I'm still alive [ __ ]
because I'm not a celebrity thanks for
sharing I know we thought that she gave
you a lot we ate all of it yeah like
this once you didn't know we we chose
not to share alright so this takes place
in Michigan this 47 year old woman lost
her job because apparently that was like
a going-away party for this one like her
co-worker and she brought brownies in
this lady has a loud mouth cuz she was
telling people she was gonna put
laxatives in it as a joke like how funny
or as like that
I don't know but revenge brownie I would
she tell people at work or just are
other people the company received a tip
from an employee I seen so yeah I worked
Ruth had a lot of mouth watch this
[ __ ] when they catch killers who
are bragging to people that they killed
the girl in the news or whatever she's a
rookie prankster yeah so then that
when police were called in she initially
denied it she was like no one these
brownies are great and then the police
said all right well we're gonna forensic
ly test these brownies for tempering
wasting our [ __ ] tax dollars she's
like okay yeah I did bakery bub
laxatives in it but since they caught it
before anyone and just that anything
Jimmy there were no charges against her
you know she just lost her job how do we
get the police involved with now any
company oh because everybody received it
I was hoping you were gonna say that the
cops are like all right so we're just
gonna sit here until you eat all of them
and then we're gonna see let me really
cops really can't do [ __ ] like that I
also wonder if you could bake the
laxatives out of it you know when you
use alcohol and you're like making rum
cake or whatever the process of baking
it eliminates all alcohol that's because
it evaporates so yeah if they use like a
diuretic
I think it's called magnesium something
somebody comes along jar no Kabang knees
not my music it could it could evaporate
and evaporate the liquid isn't the part
that gives you is the chemical so you
can evaporate chemical liquid is so it
helps but alcohol is also a chemical but
there's like alcohol into the liquid and
if that part of that brace it vaporizes
there's no there's nothing in like like
maybe he's saying that I can cancel it
out somehow maybe I don't know it might
well no it's probably more like we break
the process can make the alcohol go away
cuz I know alcohol like I cook with you
know cooking sake wine and all that
stuff and then it just turns sweet the
flavor stays the flavor stays but
alcohol content is gone sugar doesn't
burn off the alcohol burns off same
thing with rum cake you eat a whole
thing you will never get drunk yeah I
don't like rum cake because it tastes
like you'll love my mom oh [ __ ] I like
it I probably didn't probably lied when
you said you did but Gio
everyone's trying to scam you say Oh
bringing us the food you see something
really nice but it's pretty much
covering this up okay well I think you
said something like if anything you said
something like true marry straight for
life I don't usually like rum cake but
if I had to I eat this one
and they're like can you have another
slice you want another slice No
can your mom made rum cake again cuz I
want to bring ice cream with it and eat
it with it
her rum cake is bombed yeah they added
last time I ate the whole [ __ ]
thanks for dissing my mom Tiffany no I
didn't I love your mom antenna jeweler
happy birthday happy Mother's I ain't
happy everything extra all the time I
love it but we're not gonna fight you're
not gonna split up our friendship okay
rich is so jealous of our love I saw a
picture of your mom in the bathroom oh
[ __ ] yeah I did see that and the rub
cake was all in the toilet
a bunch of knives in Tiff's purse so I
have a purse in her pocket pocket yeah
anyway this lady here at least she got
fired for tampering with them town and
what you just wanted to see some people
[ __ ] come on yeah was it revenge was
their motive
well yeah apparently she did have beef
with that co-worker that was leaving but
why the whole office thinking maybe
that's why she had a big mouth and she
was telling me office or no one else
with you like I'm gonna poison the
kool-aid no one took the kool-aid but
that person why she should've just made
a small batch for her and like a little
going-away decorator all pretty put a
little bear that's why I always wanted
to befriend the crazy person in the dorm
because if they kill everybody else that
he'll give me a warning yeah they'll
come in they'll be like hey today's not
a good day to go inside the dorms what
do think I married this guy that's like
the mass shooter crazy if they come up
to you in class they're like you are
nice to me didn't that happen in
Columbine yeah one of the girls like
said they're like they're nice yeah
that's why you should be nice to
everybody yeah because you never know
only hate in the heart but not in the
mouth keep it repressed I feel like the
ones that look like they're like
socially weird and awkward it's not
because I'm afraid they're gonna shoot
me up it's more like I feel like they
deserve to be treated a little nicer
just because other people won't do it
same because I got bullied a lot when I
was a kid yeah so you're like the
stripper when a guy a really ugly guy or
like a guy with broken legs come into
the strip club you give them that extra
attention yeah
yeah Davis that kinda but this stripper
has an angle yeah this was very genuine
and kind-hearted are you giving a lap
dance for free this year that's that
then that would be day like this guy's
missing some legs I'm pretty sure she's
charging still and he's like welcome
giving her extra because no one's ever
loved and sometimes like there they are
kind of like [ __ ] weird and they're
socially awkward oh yeah you know what
just deal with it first I wanna be if
they want you just deal with it it makes
them feel good and you move on you know
what I mean it's just a little weird
where they want to follow you home
become best friends but you know you
just make them feel good
yeah I'm a [ __ ] magnet what do you did
[ __ ] no cuz I think I just like people
as individuals so whenever I was at
school like in elementary school I
didn't realize that some of the friends
that I made were special oh and I just
didn't know until I grew up and I was
like oh [ __ ] like and I got closer to
one of my friends older brothers and
then he was telling me like yeah dude my
little brother is like he has a slow
developing mind and then so we were
probably at the same level at
kindergarten if the way you said it dojo
like it sounds like it's so sweet now
when you say like it means you don't
really see their disability you see them
as people but the way you said it was
like I'm a [ __ ] magnet you know I
thought you were just talking about like
nor like just no no but like you know
non special people but then you're
actually talking about yeah I had a lot
of special friends but it's a how you
reflect on it like I reflect on it
differently because I feel like he's I
yeah my brother like he's a little
special and I'm like damn I lost to a
big chest like three times no but I grew
apart from him because you know like I
just matured and then he was he had slow
progress but we were still cool yeah
but then in junior high already like
he's still like in third grade in the
head yeah and I had another friend he
was like my best friend in India one
time we were playing in his front yard
and I think we're in fourth grade or
something and he got a big pile of dog
[ __ ] and he just went he's [ __ ]
smeared and all my
yeah and I was like why would you do
that
and he goes you could go in the pool and
wash it off and then I didn't real I
thought I just thought he was like
regular and I'm like later I'm like oh
yeah he's kind of not there
one of my friends her younger brother is
autistic and then for us you don't like
when you go up in like like a bunch of
Asian dudes and like Korean churches
like bullying is like the way to show
love yeah your favorite put like younger
kid you would always like Punk up a
little bit a little bit more than the
other ones yeah so I really like this
kid started Punk up a little bit you
don't I mean but I didn't realize that
he was autistic and so he was taking it
in like a very bad way I just thought I
just really liked the kid a lot you
bullied a Knost autistic kid yeah a
little bit sure did you punch what at
the face yes I was trying to show love
and then one day my mom was like hey are
you like bullying the kid it's like my
favorite I like him a lot she goes well
he was like you know he's like a little
you know different nose and I looked at
him and I was like no [ __ ] way and
then I started observing him a lot more
I was it oh [ __ ] he might he might be a
little autistic cuz even his parents
didn't realize and I brought it up to
his sister one day I was like do you
think like he might be autistic cuz my
brother was a psych major he was
learning about it and he was like
telling me that that might be the case
and you know like Asian people they
don't want to think anything bad about
their kids like no it's not he's not
they did find out later on that he was
huh I felt [ __ ] terrible yeah because
he couldn't interpret what I was doing
because all the other kids got bullied
too in the church I felt so [ __ ] bad
dude I was the opposite so I got bullied
by an autistic ya know not just ik Down
syndrome so she and she's much bigger
than me and we were on the playground
because so my dad would play baseball
tournaments and during that time I was
like on all day thing so there was a
park nearby though my mom would just let
me go play and so I was playing and this
girl just kept coming up and kicking me
in the stomach like hard like what
knocked the wind out of me and then like
I would try to get away from her she
pulled my hair like she was full-on like
beating me up basically like then she'd
go in high-five these other kids were
like yeah you got her and
like they'd like high-five each other
also was she being manipulated yeah yeah
cuz the other kids the regular kids were
taking or if you [ __ ] oh okay kid
dance uh yeah so she would like follow
me and beat me up and like the kids
would like yeah you got over again like
that kind of thing I was like I was like
and I was like crying myself too so went
crying back to my modeling this girl
kicked me like five times and then did
your mom beat up Burano so my mom's like
I'm gonna go get her and so she goes and
then she's like oh that's the girl oh no
can't say anything to her and likewise
she kicked me like a bunch and she's
like yeah we'll have a conversation
later yeah basically like she couldn't
find the girl's parents so like she
knows yeah she she was gonna go tell the
kid off you know like reprimand this kid
but then she found out that it was like
you know there's no point yeah your
mom's so nice like when I was like [ __ ]
that's not fair she hurt me whenever I
got beat up as a kid even though my dad
was so like anti-violence and he was a
pastor he would be like did you get beat
up by this kid he goes cool well go back
and fight you know and then let's get
the Korean side to Korea yeah I must
take revenge yeah
[Music]